hello everyone
and thank you for joining us for today's
e-seminar which is part of agilent
technology's cell
analysis webinar series
my name is sarah burrows i am the
product manager
for seahorse xf analyzers at agilent
and i will be your host for this
e-seminar before i
introduce our speaker for today allow me
to share a bit about agile and our
products for cell analysis
agilent is a leader in life sciences
clinical research
diagnostics and applied chemical markets
with over 14 000 employees worldwide
our company provides laboratories with
instruments
services consumables applications
and expertise to enable our customers to
gain the insights they seek
our cell analysis solutions for energy
metabolism measurements include the sea
horse xf platform
for label free high sensitivity assays
as well as soluble metabolic sensors for
a convenient plate reader workflow
today i'm pleased to welcome dr yu ting
sung
as our presenter she is an institute
research scientist
and project leader at the therapeutics
discovery division of
md anderson dr sun got her phd
at the university of illinois at
urbana-champaign
working with dr jay chen studying the
mtor pathway she conducted her post-doc
training at genentech
with jeff settlemen studying metabolic
rewiring and drug
resistance at md anderson she has been a
co-leader
and critical contributor to the
pre-clinical work of multiple drug
discovery programs
including early stage tumor metabolism
programs
involving the oxfoss inhibitor a
sorry iacs-10759
that is currently in phase 1 clinical
trials
it is this latest work that dr sun will
share with us today
before i hand it over to you ting a
couple of housekeeping notes
there will be a question and answer
period immediately following the talk
to help us get to as many of your
questions as possible
we encourage you to type in your
questions in the chat
window during your presentation
and we will get to those questions when
the
dr son has finished with that
i will hand over the presentation to you
ting
all right uh thank you so much sarah for
the nice introduction
many thanks to agilent for giving me the
opportunity to present our work at this
forum and hello everyone and as sarah
mentioned earlier i work for the
therapeutics discovery division at
university of texas at md anderson
cancer center
so this is a biotech-like department
that is embedded
under academic institute and a major
cancer hospital
it's my great pleasure to share with you
some of our research
in targeting metabolic synthetic
lethality to the inc
for oncology setting today
so here is the outline of my
presentation today
after a brief introduction i'd like to
share with you
two published stories one is targeting
pgd
in fh mutated cancer and the other is
targeting oxfords in glycolysis
deficient tumor
through these two stories i hope you can
appreciate the
utilization of the seahorse technology
in
biotech early stage rnd work and
and last i would like to share with you
some unpublished work
in on developing a seahorse i say to
support phase one clinical trial
uh of our oxford inhibitor ix-10759
so just to clarify uh this is for
research use only this is
uh uh not meant for
diagnostic procedures and
not on the clear setting and now to
enable decision making for the patients
so with that and the
algebra metabolism is a key feature of
the cancer cells
so an ethical review written by um
hanahan and bob weinberg
in 2011 has included deregulating
cellular energetics
as a key hallmark of cancer
the rapid proliferation of cancer cells
simply require
more energy like atp and micro molecules
to to enable that therefore the south
has to rewire its metabolizing network
to meet such demands because of that
that opens many potential opportunities
for targeting tumor metabolism in cancer
therapy
so this is a very busy slide and um
what i i i hope you can appreciate is
there are many chemical probes
experimental therapies or even
approved drugs out there to target the
tumor metabolism network
so this include anti-metabolites these
will be the mimic
over the natural metabolites in inside a
human cells
an example would be uh 5fu which is a
mimic of uridine
and and that is actually approved the
chemotherapy
that has been used for many years in the
clinic
and there are on this slide we can also
see
there are some drugs or
or chemical probes targeting glucose
metabolism the so-called wobbly effect
um there are approaches targeting amino
acid metabolism
example with that is the gis inhibitor
for targeting glutamine metabolism there
are
approaches to targeting lipid metabolism
redox homeostasis
and mitochondria as well
and in no doubt of potential therapeutic
opportunities in targeting human tablets
and however this is not a easy field for
therapeutics either
there are many challenges out there and
i i summarizes some of the
you know key challenges from a
biological biologist point of view
so these are actually three uh
challenges that
intertwined they are connected with each
other one is a metabolic bypass
and adaptation the metabolism network
is so intrinsic to ourselves
it's so critical over evolution
therefore
nature has come up with a mechanism uh
to ensure it's working if one pathway is
failed there is a backup mechanism there
is probably a backup of the backup
mechanism as well
therefore when we hit one node of the
metabolism one pathway
they will almost always be bypass coming
up metabolic adaptation occurring
and the second is the therapeutic index
because many of these mechanisms
that occur in normal cells as well very
often we're highly relying on the rap
just the rapid proliferation of cancer
cells to argue for a therapeutic index
and thirdly for many um experimental
therapies for human metabolism
uh there is a lack of a clearly defined
genetic context
uh probably with the exception of idh
inhibitors
um most for most of the case we
it's not like uh egfr inhibitor are
targeting egf-4 mutated and non-small
cell lung cancer
or like and track inhibitor targeting
and track fusion cancer
for the tumor metabolism targets very
often we don't have that
so to overcome the challenges our
hypothesis
is uh we think we should target
synthetically lethal interactions
basically particularly for loss of
function mutations of metabolic and
enzymes that will generate additional
metabolic adaptation
and therefore by targeting such
synthetic lethal injections
hopefully we can improve the therapeutic
index
and we can reduce metabolic adaptation
as well
so the cancer genome sequencing network
has uh
you know has or uh i identify the
knowledge
and the oncogenes and the tumor
suppressors
for the metabolism enzymes there are a
few
uh mostly commonly mutated enzymes
that serve as our metabolic oncogenes or
tumor suppressors
the most commonly mutated one is idh
idh1 and idh2
these are general function mutations so
basically these are oncogenes
the gamma function mutations on idh well
again some epigenetic function and that
will drive
tumor formation uh work pioneered by
agios and others
um and most recently agiles have
developed
idh inhibitors that are have already
been approved
for ibh mutated leukemia
and these are the metabolic oncogenes
but tumor suppressors
um fh and
sdh these are two enzymes similar to idh
these are in the tca cycle these two um
these two enzymes they actually have
loss of function mutations
not organo function mutations uh in
tumor
these loss of function mutations these
two on oxford's deficiencies
because these are tumor suppressors we
cannot directly targeting fh
in hsdh and how do we target
fh mutated or sdh mutated tumors
i'd like to say a few more words about
fh and sdh
fh is fumarate hydrotase
and it occurs more often in this disease
called hlrcc
this is the hereditary uh myomitosis
in renal cell carcinoma it's a very
aggressive subtype of renal cell
carcinoma it's featured by germline
mutation in fh
then the mutation in the second copy
over fh will lead to a tumor formation
and also sdh substitute dehydrogenase
this occurs more often in paragon glioma
in the angioglan field mesotomers
and the gastric gif the stomach tumors
and of course renal cell carcinoma as
well
these are very rare diseases i have to
say
um they tend to spread with a very smart
tumor volume so they're very aggressive
and there are currently no effective
therapies uh targeting
these type kinds of tumors
so to identify potential uh therapeutic
targets
um for these um this type of cancer
we started with model selection we use a
seahorse essay
to evaluate metabolic rewiring in a
panel of
cancer cell lines and you are probably
pretty familiar with that the seahorse
measures uh
can measure e-car an old car and
also a ppr this is the proton production
rate
so here we actually take the ratio of a
pdr versus old car
ppr stands for the glycolysis rate just
like e car
and the old car stands for oxygen
consumption that's the
on oxford's oxidative phosphorylation
rate but basically the ratio will tell
us uh the rate
over glycolysis versus oxidative
phosphorylation the higher the ratio
the more glycolytic the cell line is
so through sequence analysis of this
panel over selected cell lines
you can clearly see there are two
outliers one is the green bar
the mb1 cells it's a glycolic it's
clearly glycolysis deficient
there is pretty much undetectable amount
of proton production in this cell line
and i will talk about the sala in a
little bit later and the other side line
is the light line on the very right
this so called uk 262 cells clearly it
has a high glycolysis
rate and low an oxidative
phosphorylation rate
this is actually a fh mutated renal cell
carcinoma cell line
this is a model we can use uh to conduct
a screening for potential targets
for the fh mutated cancer so we
conducted a loss of function genetic
screen
um using the uk262 saline
basically we infected this fh mutated
saline
with a port of sshrna containing
antiviruses
this is a library contains uh
shrine it's targeting about 300
metabolic genes the cells are infected
the pure selected
48 hours after a selection the cells
the reference library will be collected
and the cells will continue
to cultured and selected for another
two to three weeks by then whatever
shrine is that has a growth disadvantage
will be depleted in the cell lines
and we also collected uh these cells we
conducted a barcode sequencing
basically each sshrna is conjugated into
a barcode
using sequencing we delineate the bars
coding barcode
and abundance of the experimental
library versus the reference library
which tells us
which genes are specifically depleted
during the culturing over two to three
weeks
so in the end interestingly in the uk
262 cells
esthetics mutated cell line out of the
about 300
metabolism genes and the ptd um
is clearly a top hit in the uk 262 cell
line
basically uh genetic depletion of a tdd
causes the biggest growth disadvantage
in this cell line
then this is not uh for miscues to hit
because uh a few cell lines we tested
those are the fhy type style lines
and pcb is not hit in any of these star
lines
so this is data from the functional
genomics screen
then um then we ask ourselves um pgd
looks interesting what is it what does
it do
so this is a an enzyme in the pentose
phosphate pathway
the slide here you see the glycolysis
network we have glycolysis
um we have the pentose phosphate pathway
so basically pgd
is set at the interface of the oxidative
branch and the non-oxidative branch of
the pentose phosphate pathway
so this is a rate limiting enzyme in ppp
because of the connection between ppp
and the glycolysis
the pdd inhibition actually pgd is
actually critical for glycolysis
even though this is not a direct
glycolysis enzyme
there are two key functions of pcd one
is
it generates an adph therefore
it's critical for redox and also ptg
generates
phosphate five the right the ribose
5-phosphate
so this is a five-carbon sugar basically
pgd converts
six carbon sugar to five carbon sugar
therefore pgd is critical for nucleotide
synthesis
so that appears to be an important
enzyme for cell proliferation
to make sure our screening data is valid
we follow that with our target
evaluation work
first using the urk262 thyroid with sh
loss cell function mutation
we infected the cells with the dox
induced for hairpins over pgd
and we showed genetic inhibition of pgdd
robustly suppresses the cell
proliferation
and also you see on the western blot on
the right that induces
robust apoptosis of the cells as well
and interestingly this effect is context
specific
when we use the isogenic cell line when
we are
reintroduced y-type fh to urk-262-thor
lines
um this while we use the seahorse ac to
conform
uh this rescued cell line indeed has
oxygen consumption restored so then um
we knocked down pgd in the fh rescued
cell line
we see a much less pronounced
anti-proliferative effect with the
genetic tools
and most importantly we no longer see
induction
of apoptosis by pgd genetic inhibition
so this data confirms the context
specific essentiality of pgd
in addition to that to make sure um the
effect we see
is not due to off-target activity of the
hairpins
we took two approaches one is uh the
classical approach called
genetic rescue with the essential nail
resistant
cdma here we overexpress um
shpdd-resistant
pdbcdna in the cells and you can see on
the top
on the left over expression of control
enzyme gfp
that has no impact on the effect over
shped on cell proliferation
however the overexpression over pgd
that completely rescues the
anti-proliferative effects of
the and the second we're very
we're very fortunate here we can use a
cell line called mb1 i mentioned earlier
this is actually a pdd homozygous
deleted cell line it does not express
pdb
at all and when we introduce
dox-inducible hairpins to
this cell line and there is absolutely
no effect
no uh on cell proliferation this is a
dramatic difference
from the urk262 cell lines so this piece
of
data clearly tells us the response we
see
is indeed due to the on target activity
of pcd
and therefore i i think people can
pretty
probably appreciate is that with a lot
of our tumor metabolism
um targets uh very often we see a very
robust in vitro effect
when taking that in vivo the effect is
becoming far less pronounced
so it's important to validate the target
in vivo
here we use uh we took the uk 262 cell
lines
covering stocks inducible hairpins in
vivo
we waited until the tumors are well
established they are around the 300
cubic millimeter now we give the mice
oxycycline
through their food which will induce the
expression of the sh
rnas therefore induce knock down over
pcd
protein and we see robust regression
of the tumor and the tumor
soon become pretty much unmeasurable
and we keep the mice um on toxic cycling
diets
for a few actually for half year and we
um we this response is very durable
within half a year we do not see our the
signs of regrowth of the tumor and to
make sure the effect
is we see again in vivo is in due
is due to on target effects we evaluated
the so-called invisible target
engagement
here we conducted a metabolomics uh with
the tumors
from the study um these tumors were
treated with the doxycycline for a week
then we evaluate the
how much metabolite it is there in this
tumor
and we see robust accumulation of
6-phosphogluconate
which is the substrate of pgd so
therefore
we achieve illegal target engagement as
well here
so uh we also delineated the mechanism
of action
over the synthetic lethality between ptd
inhibition and the fh loss of function
mutation
so at a high level it's through
multi-prone effects
including a suppressed suppression of
glycolysis which occurs actually in both
fh y-type and s-h-mutated context
and also pct inhibition impedes redux
homeostasis
and inhibits glutening reductive
capacitation
and the later two only occurs in the fh
mutated context
of the oxford's deficient context so in
the next
three slides i'm going to show you the
data supporting the mechanism of action
and
that is uh highlighted in the bullets
here
first we conducted a um the lc massback
mass specs
metabolomics um analysis
um both we we did both the steady-state
metabolomics
and also i did the uh c13
labeled isotope tracing to conduct flux
analysis
the the cartoon on the left shows uh the
metabolites that are either accumulated
or depleted with the pgd inhibition
and also the changes in flux with the
pgd in addition
what is pretty clear is we have a
reduced lactate with the pgd inhibition
so
pc inhibition does suppress glycolysis
what is pretty interesting is that we
only see on decreased
glycolysis metabolites um that is more
downstream
but the upstream metabolites like
glucose 6-phosphate
fructose 6-phosphate these are actually
are increased
so we see a breakage between our
um pfk and the exactly mechanism how
six pcd innovation suppresses um the pfk
staff that still requires a further
investigation
and on the ppp side a ptd inhibition
reduces the flux into both the oxidative
arm
and the non-oxidative arm over the
pentose phosphate pathway
so this is actually a mechanism that is
similar in both
fh mutated and fh y type
context then the next
is a pgd inhibition because
um because of ptd's role in
nadph production we asked does that have
an impact in
redox homeostasis here we show
genetic inhibition over pgd
causes a robust reduction of loss
and this is uh extremely reproducible
in robust increase at ross and going and
since we see this data we have been
using these cells as a positive control
for
our roth experiments
then in addition to genetic inhibition
of pgd also we use a
amino nicotinomide which is
a chemical probe that inhibits pgd
and we see as short as the overnight
treatment with the six amino
nicotinamide we also see a robust
induction of roth in the urk262 cells
and such induction of loss is critical
for
the anti-proliferative phenotype of pcb
inhibition
because when we use a good design to
reduce
grass and we also
see reduce the cell proliferation under
the treatment of the six amino
nicotinomides
so this mechanism actually only occurs
in the sh
mutated context so that is a explanation
of the synthetic efficiency between
pgd inhibition and fh loss of function
mutation
so the third mechanism is um in
is a pgd's impact on reductive
carboxylation of rooting
a few years ago uh some uh seminal work
by rafty brandinis and
and a few others they show in the fh
deficient cells so the cells are
actually no longer
relying on glucose to produce a citrine
and acetyl coa for the pita synthesis
because the tca cycle is a broken
so with the intact tca cycle the tcs
cycle would run clockwise
and in a in the fh deficient cells
the cells would rely on glutamine
which will feed the tca cycle then the
tca cycle will
run in the fashion that is
anti-clockwise
basically glutamine enters tca cycle
becomes upper ketoglutarate
then generates citrate to feed
the fatty acid synthesis so
this um this is so called uh reductive
carboxylation of the glutamine
and this mechanism can actually be
measured uh using the stable isotope
tracing uh
using the lc mass spec mass specs so
here uh
we use a c13 a labeled glutening to feed
the cells and examine
where the glutamine goes uh in the
bottom in the urk 262 cells
we were able to detect a clear portion
of the
m plus 5 citrine so these
are the situated from glutamine through
reductive carboxylation
and with the pdd inhibition you can see
a clear reduction
of the m plus 5 century suggests
suggesting reduction
over reductive uh carboxylation of the
glutamine
and on the right on in the sh1650
which is a fh y type cell line
we don't see a major portion of
reductive
carboxylation and the pgp inhibition
does not suppress the m plus five
citrate here
so these data suggests pcd inhibition
also
has a significant impact on reductive
carboxylation of the glutamine in the
atheist mutated cells
so to summarize the first part of my
talk
through functional genomics approach we
identified a synthetic lethal
interaction between ptd inhibition and
and and oxford's deficiency and the
thorough in visual and illegal target
validation work has validated the ptd
as a target in sh mutated cancer
and and we have also deviated such a
multi-uh prone the mechanism of action
of pgd here
so these data would suggest we can
target ptd
in fh mutated cancer
since the synthetic lethal interaction
is the two way
um we also asked can we do
the other way around can we target fh
or oxford in ptd deficient cancer
as you may know we have our axos
inhibitor
uh that is actually under uh clinical
trials
this is the ix-10759 so this
is a complex one inhibitor um over the
year
um of oxidative phosphorylation um it
has the
lone animal activity and cell-based
functional assays so this is a very
potent and a specific
compound it is suitable for uvo using
it has good for uh pharmaco uh kinetic
properties to enable
daily oral dosing and we see those
dependent efficacy
uh with a uh pharmacodynamics readout
in relevant preclinical models and there
are two
uh phase one clinical trials that are
actually ongoing with iax10759
one is a leukemia trial and the other is
a
solid tumor trial so
um some highlight over ix1079
it targets uh now complex one basically
a complex one um generates an ad nad
converts in a due to an ad plus and
because this is coupled to oxygen
consumption at the later stage of the
electron transport chain
that's why suppressing uh complex one or
the suppressed
oxygen consumption so we have again
used the seahorse uh us with our small
cell lung cancer h460 cell lines
and here we show the real-time injection
of ix-10759
to the cells will be able to potentially
suppress oxygen consumption
we know the mechanism of action of the
compound is indeed
due to complex one because uh we have
generated a
acquired resistance um models
a clone towards ix-10759
and a resistance mechanism is actually a
mutation
on a a complex one this clone called
nd1 so mutation nd1 will make
the cells resistant to ix-10759
and importantly our collaborator judy
hurst
from uk who has solved the the complex
one structure
so she also uh shows um the
direct binding between ix 1079 with
complex one
so we know where exactly uh 10759 binds
to
the complex one which is a very solid
evidence for the mechanism action of the
compound
so how do we uh uh utilize the
synthetically
little infections uh in a position
ix-10759 in the clinic
so there are actually are two potential
opportunities um
one is uh the pgd homozygous deletion
and the um
the other is called eno one homozygous
dilution
so uh ptd i mentioned earlier um
ptd inhibition suppresses a glycolysis
so
that makes sense and eno one is um
actually a glycolysis enzyme um so this
is at the
later stage of glycolysis which is a few
just a few steps
upstream of lactate dehydrogenase
so um because uh an eye oxford inhibitor
targets
oxfords and then
on the glycolysis deficient context we
think of
uh targeting oxfords that will have a
better therapeutic
index will have less metabolic
bypass and adaptation over there
so first um again this is the seahorse
data you saw previously
i want to highlight the green bar the
mb1 cells
this is a glycolysis deficient and this
is actually a pgd homozygous deleted
enzyme
and when we overexpress a ptd
in the mp1 cell we are able to
restore glycolysis you will see increase
the lactate secretion to the cells
we also see an increased e-car measured
by the c-horse i say
and this is our indeed due to the
enzymatic functional pgd
because when we overexpress the ear2
enzymatic death mutants or pgd
we no longer see such rescue of
glycolysis
so um and we tested how does oxford
inhibitor
ix 10759 work in pgd homozygous deleted
mb1 cells
uh in the mb1 cells we see a robust
single agent
activity in visual and and
um importantly when we uh
reintroduce pgd to the mb1 cells we see
a rescue
of the anti-proliferative effect
and we also did apoptosis analysis
showing in
nb1 cells the 10759 treatment actually
causes a very robust
of apoptosis so very robust single-aging
effect in vitro
and in vivo and
we again we waited until the tumors are
of decent volume is a very well
established
tumor by this stage and our treatment
with iax10759
once per day an oral dosing causes
robust regression of the tumor
this treatment is well tolerated no body
weight enough at the doses tested here
so we also confirmed the uh in vivo uh
target engagement
and pde inhibition i'm sorry 107.59
inhibition
um that are because of it suppresses
oxygen consumption
uh when therefore the tumor cells are no
longer
consuming oxygen and then and that
reduces uh hypoxia
so here the uh the immunohistochemistry
data shows the
tension family and treatment eliminates
hypoxia in the tumor cells
this is also an important secondary
mechanism action of ix pencil timeline
oh um so far i've only showed you one
model
of our ptd homozygous deletion
we also use shrna um to
generate our second model with the pcd
deletion
uh in oxford professional model
so this is a h1975 non-muscle on cancer
model
in vitro we see a very nice synergistic
effect
between shpcd and ix-10759
and in vivo in h1975
cells with the dox inducible shptd ptd
inhibition single agent actually does
not have
very much effect in vivo in the oxford's
professional model and the 105.9
and it has some response which is the
red line you can see on the right
it definitely suppresses tumor growth
however the model progresses on
treatment
and the combination of pgd
inhibition and 10759 is able to cause
robust tumor regression so in a second
model with a
reduced level of pct we're able to see a
robust response of ix 107.59
so uh this is about the pcb homozygous
deleted population
and and the evil one homozygous deleted
population is
a second potential synthetic lethal
opportunity with ix-10759
so this was uh occurs more often in
glioblastoma style line this context was
i
identified by foreign mirror and
long-term
through their seminal work in a in a
collateral collateral lethality analysis
so our using a two you know one
homozygous deleted
glioblastoma style lines one is the d423
and the other is 56 we see
a robust single agent activity in vitro
from ix 107.59
and importantly when we overexpress you
know one in these models
we see much less
anti-proliferative response from
oxford's inhibitor
and in these two models we also see a
robust optosis
by treatment using ix-10759
and in vivo we utilized an isotopic
uh uh model this is the
intracranial gbm model developed by uh
the fred the fred lunch group at md
anderson cancer center
so basically the mice we made a boat
and we we made a we voted the mice on
their brain
then implanted the um the you know one
homozygous deleted
cell lines uh into the mouth brain once
the tumors
are well established confirmed by
pre-treatment
and mri then the mice were eroded into a
daily oral dosing with ix-10759
these mice were dosed for four weeks
then we conducted a
post-dosing mri to look at how the
tumors looked like after
four weeks of dosing and after that we
monitor the over
our survival of the mice so
you can appreciate in the minor images
here is uh
the vehicle uh treated uh mice the
tumors
continue to grow on the four weeks
period
um and the simpson timeline are treated
groups
we have reduced tumor volume and we have
a quantified
tumor volume i'm not showing uh
regression by single agent
treatment of ix-10759 and
importantly this treatment also extends
the overall
survival of the mice
so this is uh the efficacy response in
the mice
and we also conducted the companion
pharmaco
dynamics analysis i mentioned to you
earlier
tension five nine treatment would reduce
hypoxia
um this is our the tumor pd biomarker we
use
in our pre-clinical studies and uh tens
and final
and here um show inside the brain on the
intracranial model
also reduces the hypoxia
suggesting on target activity of the
compound
so um then how can we translate
such robust pre-clinical data targeting
synthetic electronically
to the actual patients uh
a key challenge here is uh
where is the patient population we did
some uh
work trying to identify the pgd
homozygous patient population
and the eno one homozygous patient
population
the pgd homozygous deleted population um
it is rare uh we're still trying to find
out
and how what is the physical way uh to
identify that patient population
and to this end we are at least able to
identify the eno one homozygous deleted
population
by collaborating with a doctor with
group at mb anderson
we analyzed our piano over gbm
human tumor samples by screening through
a total over 92 gbm
tumor samples we're able to identify at
least
three tumors that have been determined
to be at you know one homozygous deleted
what you can see on ihc images here you
know one
is specifically deleted in the tumor
cells
but they're still present on the stroma
of these human beings
so we went further to developed uh to
develop
a clear certified you know one eye tree
assay so this essay is actually
being used to uh screen and enroll
uh substrates where you know one uh
homozygous deleted in the tumor
for our clinical trial um this trial um
is not in addition to uh glioblastoma we
also
unable to identify you know what uh
homozygous deleted tumor for cancer or
carcinoma
uh so these are the two indications um
uh the clinical trial is searching for
you know
you know one and homozygous deleted
subjects
so and to summarize the second part of
my talk
and an exhaust complex one inhibitor ix
107.59 has
robust single-agent activity in
glycolysis deficient tumor
that are featured by homozygous deletion
of either pgd
or eno-1 and you know one population
can be identified in our
gbm and the country or carcinoma using a
clear certified ihvsa
and these are pretty rare patient
populations but i would think
this is area that the impact can be made
and the ongoing ix 2759 solid tumor
trial is actually
actively screening and recruiting
subjects with you know one
homozygous deletion in the tumor
last but not least i want to share with
you
some of the unpublished work on
on developing uh seahorse icing to
support the phase one clinical trial
of ix-10759 um
since 107.59 suppresses the oxygen
consumption
we'll show you uh data using the sea
horse i say on cell lines
and can we use this on immediate samples
on ml pdx
models and potentially on human ml blood
as well
so we have this is the layout of the
assay we take uh
human blood or mlpdx samples through
cycle isolation
we reached on the the cancer cells
and through our cd3 and cd19 depletion
we got the viable cancer cells
then plated on our seahorse plate using
uh the using uh the celtec coating
so uh using uh the pdx model
um first the efficiency data with the ml
pdx model
ix 107.59 those dependently suppresses
extends the overall survival of the mice
as well as
one mig per cake once per day oral
dosing and also at two point five
minutes
per day per day and also 7.5
make per cake so utilizing these those
on pd essays
using the the sea wars um and i say on
mlpdx model
xvivo we're able to achieve reduced
dependent
suppression of maximal or
by ix-10759 and we tested four different
pdx models using xv or c-horse assay
so we further tested with our primary
human ml samples
taking a human and ml blood the samples
were
isolated enriched with our cancerous
cells
then we conducted extravagant treatment
with ix-10759 for four hours
then plated them on the seahorse plate
and here
we show xvivo spiking over 107.59
is able to importantly reuse ocar
with human ml samples in adult dependent
manner
as low as 10 nanomolar of compound we
are able to suppress alcohol about
50 percent
so and we also further validate the
the essay for clinical use um in
a research setting we um
we evaluate the uh the reproducibility
and the variability
of the essay by looking at a few human
sub
subjects we see a very little uh
inter subject variability and very uh
resist on ensure subject variability
that's likely caused by the particular
treatment
these are humans got um so because
of the robust preclinical data we
developed the essay to support to the
phase one clinical trial
um in the end on a sea horse plate a 96
well sea horse plate
both the human and male samples
isolated from human blood
were seated at 400k cells per well
we included uh some positive control in
the cells which is the
oci ml3 which is this is a leukemia
style line
she also make sure um the uh the
the old car observed is in range in
every single
few hours plate we run we're building uh
it's a linear uh linearity seeding
control using the
ocr ml three star lines so the cells
are seated at 400k 300k 200k and 100k
um per well so we want to make sure uh
the
oka detected with the human and ml
samples that is
in range of uh the serial dilution of
ocr ml3 cells so this essay is uh
has been completed uh implemented
in our phase one clinical trial so this
is uh the trial phase one trial uh study
of tencent five nine
uh in subjects with a relapsed or
refractory and
acute myeloid leukemia so
the um the exploratory uh goal
of this trial is a pharmacodynamic
biomarker of activity and one of the
pharmacodynamic biomarker is the
seahorse assay
so a peripheral blood is harvested the
pre and
post dosing with ix tension fine line
um so i i my last data slide i want to
uh show you some preliminary data from
the trial
um so the the human subject
were enrolled into the trial we got a
predose
a blood then we also gave a pre up a
post
a post-dosing blood six hour after
dosing
then after a one-week washout period um
of the compound to let the campaign
completely get out of the system
and then the subjects entered into once
a day oral dosing
then again we have a pre and post blood
harvested
throughout the dosing period first um
we analyzed the human pk of ix 107.9759
from the one mig per cake
cohort the pk data here shows uh
from three different uh subjects um
dosed at
some level you see very uh less um
acute subject to subject variation in pk
and this compound has good bio uh bio
availability
in humans and uh and
the uh the old car analysis the seahorse
analysis
with the blast isolated from substrates
from the trial
also shows um pre and volt post
dose okay levels the the red dots here
is um the blood taken six hours opposed
to dosing of ix 10 75 9
and the black dots is the matching
pre-dosing blood and clearly we can see
some reduction of alcohol from
from samples from the clinical trial
so um with that i
would like to uh acknowledge uh and my
department
the md anderson therapeutic uh discovery
division
um so particularly the oxford team
it takes a a village to get this amount
of
this kind of work down joe maslock is
the project lead
of the ix 2759 program
the biology lead and amelia is the
chemistry lead of the program
and marina around the you know at phase
one clinical trial for the
for the of the leukemia trial and team
yap runs
uh solid uh uh trial with i expensive
time nine
and i want to also acknowledge uh
jennifer marliner who uh
who did the uh xbox on ml work
uh in the for the in the pre-clinical
setting
um so i would also like to acknowledge
uh ambience and um
the therapeutics discovery division
leadership uh phil jones tim hoffman
and uh julio jorita and our
collaborators the foreign mirror
uh ignacio withdrew and ron depino and a
few others which i don't need to mention
throughout this presentation
and with that i would like to again uh
thank uh the opportunity to present at
this forum
and thank you so much for joining me
today
and i'm happy to take your questions
thanks you ting that was a very
interesting presentation
we got to hear a lot of good stories and
we do have several questions so we'll go
ahead and get started with the q a
portion of the webinar some of you have
already
chatted in questions but if you have a
question that you'd like to ask
feel free to submit it and we'll
either get to those questions uh before
the end of the hour and we have about 10
minutes left
and if not we'll we'll follow up with
you by email to answer
the questions that we aren't able to get
to
so we'll go ahead and get started and
the first
question is about the compound
a little bit um the around some
questions around the specificity
of this compound for
cancer cells compared to non-cancer
cells and then related
um you know related to that
is does it have properties that is it
but more specific than other ox
complex one inhibitors does it make a
better
candidate for treatment than other
complex one inhibitors
yeah so i think there are actually a
couple of questions embedded here
so the first question is um about
the specificity of this compound
and how is that compared with our other
ox inhibitor
this is a a highly specific
and potent uh oxford complex one
inhibitor
and it is it works in that nanomolar
range
um here i'm i guess um when i'm asked
compared with other oxford inhibitors
people are talking about
potentially like metformins and forming
metformin from foaming works at
micromolar range
and this compound works in nanomolar
range
um and we have fully delineated the
mechanism action of this compound by
identifying a resistant mutations
towards this compound uh single point
mutation
in nd1 in the complex one were able to
render resistance towards ix-10759
so this clearly suggests uh this the
on-target
specific activity of the compound
and i think i heard the other question
is uh
the action of this compound in cancer
cells
versus normal cells in terms of
oxygen consumption it does not do
anything different
between cancer and normal cells it will
suppress
oxygen consumption no matter what
although very often we see cancer cells
have a probably high level of oxygen
consumption than normal cells
just the base level then
what give us the therapeutic index
is the specific metabolic vulnerability
in cancer cells how the cancer cells
become more
dependent on oxygens you know there are
a lot of evidence
in the literature suggests providing uh
rationale over targeting oxbows
including targeting cancer
are targeting acquired drug resistance
so
the two contacts i presented here these
are
glycolysis deficient contexts so because
these
cancer cells are already deficient in
glycolysis
they become solely rely on oxfords for a
lot of things
that's why we think they will have a
great therapeutic
index there
okay thanks so much you ting um
a technical question um about
the the um in vitro studies
um are you modulating the concentration
of the
glucose in your media at all or
uh i guess you can tell just if you can
share with us
the substrate concentration
um so
so we run the seahorse i say in a few
different
settings including uh like pre-clinical
setting and uh
um you know the supporting the clinical
trial
supporting the phase one trial so um
in the pre-clinical uh basic research
experiments the glucose concentration
uh we have used a range of
concentrations but
on it appears does not matter
we will always see suppression over
oxygen consumption by acts 10759
no matter how much glucose we use
then for the supporting the
the clinical trial so we further
optimize the essay
we tend to use the so-called
physiological
relevant concentration of glucose
and i i don't remember the exact glucose
concentration on top of my brain but i
believe
this is uh also mentioned in the nature
medicine paper that came out in 2018
and i'm happy you know to provide the
concentrate the amount of glucose we use
by email as well
okay thank you um
the oh we have another technical
question um
and this has to do with the fccp
so it looked like you were primarily
running the
cell mitostress test and the question is
for testing the human primary cells
do you need to optimize the fccb
concentration for
each individual or are you
stan have you standardized on one fcc
concentration
for all of the patient samples
yeah that's a great question and i
initially had a slide like that but then
i took that out
so um yeah so definitely even what
i'm sure this question is from someone
who knows this i say really well um
um even with the cell lines uh we have
we always have to optimize the fcct
concentration
so what we do is um well
the short answer is we do have to
optimize fccp concentration
for you know for for different subjects
so um well i let me take to this slide
so in this slide you can see there is uh
like
first part of the trial there is a
screen stage
so that means uh at this at this screen
stage we actually
gave some blood from this particular
subject
and we run that through the sea wars
essay we do
a dose titration of fccp uh
in a range that is recommended by
agilent
then based on that we will pick a
concentration
102 fccp concentration that we're
actually going to use
when we later on actually run samples
from this particular subject so that yes
needs to be determined from subject to
subject
there is a small range of variability
with that as well
okay and so then once you've
determined the dose for a given subject
then
you keep that dose consistent throughout
the
time of the course of the trial right so
your six week
later day 28 later you're using the same
fccp
as you did on day zero right
yeah exactly
thank you um
sorry hold on
i'm gonna look at the more of these
these
there was a question about solubility of
the compound but i also heard you
mention
that you know it has good
bioavailability so maybe you can tell us
about how
like how you manage the solubility in
vitro and as well as for
in vivo
um the compound is uh
i it's uh it has very good oral
bioavailability
we have always been using that through
oral dosing
when we remove those b animals
we use the 0.5 percent methyl cellulose
as the formulation so that is not a
clear solution
it is a suspension the compound has to
be our
vortexed uh in massive cellulars and
also fornicated
to help the compound to get into the
the dosing solution the formulation but
once it is there
um it is a stable and for
uh well for we we
we remake the level dosing solution once
per week
and during that week uh when we are not
using the compound we keep that
on a story plate on constant just
stirring so that make sure no compound
crashes out of the formulation
so this works very consistently and for
in vitro use
we don't have our um
very much issue uh with with the
compound solubility
as long as we use it under one
micromolar
in in media so if we go
over uh say one micromolar or over three
micromolar in media uh we will
occasionally notice a compound crashing
out of
the media so regardless this is a highly
potent compound
we we mostly uh use this compound in
like 10 nanomolar
if we want to hit it really hard as we
use
100 nanomolar in vitro so we don't have
to go to
that high concentration
great so because it is so potent
it's plenty soluble at the effective
doses
that's that's really great um so i guess
we're at the top of the hour so um
i'd like to thank you ting for
the um fantastic presentation and
great answers to our questions and i
think it's just
it's a really nice story of how
modulating metabolism can impact
tumor proliferation as well as
knowing what your the metabolic
phenotype of the cancer you're trying to
target
is will really define
the therapeutic approach that you want
to take
um for a given class of cancer different
or given you know genetic mutation
so your work really showed uh nicely
that
how you know for a very give a given set
of phenotypes
that this type of approach is
is very powerful so thanks so much dr
sun and talk to you all next time
thank you so much sarah and thank you so
much everyone for spending the time with
me i appreciate that
you